desde Toronto hasta Buenos Aires el
aniversario de Ucrania no pasó
desapercibido en el continente americano
miles de civiles salieron a las calles
para solidarizarse a un año de la
invasión rusa en Canadá la comunidad
ucraniana en el país mantuvo una vigila
conmemorativa mientras en Estados Unidos
los neoyorquinos se desplegaron en el
Time Square con carteles y banderas en
tanto que en el met opera se realizó un
concierto con los solistas ucranianos
dimitropov y vladislab
[Aplausos]
boyalsking es importante Tocar música
ucraniana en general porque humaniza
este conflicto y muestra al mundo
Quiénes somos que no somos solo números
y no somos solo palabras en una página
en América Latina las protestas se
dirigieron hacia las embajadas rusas y
apuntaron contra la figura del
presidente Vladimir Putin como en esta
movilización en Ciudad de México
en Quito los manifestantes hicieron Un
minuto de silencio
en Santiago mujeres portaron ropa típica
ucraniana
desde Lima un pequeño grupo de
inmigrantes ucranianos se reunieron
frente al consulado Ruso y lo
calificaron de Asesino mientras en
Buenos Aires miembros de la colectividad
ucraniana lamentaron las pérdidas de
seres queridos En el conflicto
todos mis días de despertarme y
enterarme de alguna horrible noticia y
sobre todo todos los días ver si mi mamá
sigue viva o no y la cantidad de amigos
que pedí en este año no ya perdí la
cuenta Así que es tristísimo el obelisco
monumento de la capital argentina se
tiñó de azul y amarillo al igual que
otros iconos del mundo un reflejo de la
solidaridad con Ucrania en tiempos de
guerra